C'est une tâche difficile
chose que nous faisons.
C'est une chose difficile,
c'est une nouveauté,
et tu sais, j'espère
que tu nous encouragerais.
Trois,
deux, un et décollez!
Je pense que c'est
une très bonne étape
pour l'avenir du vol spatial.
Tu sais, je pense que c'en est une autre
un pas vers les étoiles.
Elon Musk ne l'est pas
votre milliardaire technologique moyen.
Il est l'un des plus
des entrepreneurs fascinants
en affaires aujourd'hui.
L'homme derrière PayPal
s'attaque aux géants
de l'aérospatiale et
industries automobiles,
aux côtés des sociétés pétrolières,
le service public de l'énergie
entreprises et gagner.
Elon Musk
est un visionnaire,
quelqu'un qui vient
peut-être une fois par siècle,
qui est en train de changer
la façon dont nous fonctionnons
et la façon dont nous
regarde le monde.
À l'époque,
les gens avaient encore peur
acheter des livres en ligne,
donc mettre en place un
suite de services financiers
sur Internet était un
idée plutôt révolutionnaire,
et cette entreprise s'est transformée
être PayPal,
le service de paiement en ligne.
C'est une chose de diriger une entreprise
cela vaut un milliard de dollars.
Elon Musk en a quatre.
Mon idéologie personnelle est
une sorte de séparation en ce moment
entre essayer d'être utile
sur des trucs liés à la Terre,
qui est une énergie durable,
et puis j'essaye de
faire progresser la technologie spatiale,
afin que nous puissions établir un
ville autonome sur Mars.
De l’IA à la disruption
l'industrie automobile,
à SolarCity.
Je veux dire combien
d'autres personnes peuvent dire,
J'ai ma propre entreprise de fusées ?
Pas beaucoup.
- En termes d'espace,
Elon a complètement changé
comment nous pensons à tout.
Quand tu regardes
ce que SpaceX a fait
avec leurs fusées réutilisables,
nous assistons à de la science-fiction
des années 1950 qui prennent vie.
Les roquettes atterrissent alors qu'elles
ont toujours été censés faire.
Il essaie vraiment d'atterrir
sur un timbre-poste là-bas.
Étonnamment difficile.
Donc, Mars nous fait signe.
je suis très convaincu
que ça va
arriver dans ma vie.
- Si tu regardes
chez Tesla seul,
a changé la façon
que les automobiles
sera pour toujours dans le futur.
Il a vraiment brisé
en bas du mur
c'était impossible à briser,
et maintenant nous y sommes
une situation où
tous les grands constructeurs automobiles
changent massivement
aux voitures électriques,
et c'est une révolution
fait par un seul homme.
Il est presque comme
un vrai Iron Man
dans ce qu'il fait.
Il y a beaucoup plus
ça va arriver
avant que son histoire ne soit terminée.
Donc, je pense que nous obtenons simplement
à regarder et à être excité,
et voyez ce qui va suivre.
Beaucoup de gens pensent que
entrepreneurs à succès
je me trouve justement dans le
au bon endroit au bon moment
avec le bon produit
ou un bon service.
C'est faux.
Pourquoi ne le sont-ils pas
content de 25 millions de dollars
quand ils vendent
leur première entreprise,
puis allez dans une deuxième entreprise
pour 50 millions de dollars supplémentaires,
ou une société tierce lorsqu'ils
échouer et aller dans un autre.
Les entrepreneurs en série sont motivés.
Ils sont motivés psychologiquement,
et c'est généralement lié à
quelque chose dans leur enfance.
Elon Reeve Musk
est né à Pretoria en 1971,
le fils d'une mère canadienne
et père sud-africain.
Elon a grandi en Afrique du Sud,
et il avait un très
une éducation sans entrave.
Il a dit qu'il était
élevé essentiellement par les livres
et parfois des nounous.
Sa mère et son père
j'ai deux autres enfants.
Ils le sont, il a un plus jeune
frère et soeur,
Kimball et Tuska, mais
il semblait qu'Elon n'avait pas
beaucoup de surveillance d'adultes.
Il a dit qu'il était fondamentalement
là-bas, je construis des explosifs,
et apprendre la conduction
avec très peu de surveillance.
Il avait une passion
pour l'ingénierie,
et évidemment la physique
et les sciences aussi.
Musk était présent
École primaire de Waterkloof,
et après le divorce de ses parents,
Elon, neuf ans, est allé
vivre avec son père.
Elon à un moment donné
dans son enfance,
après le divorce de ses parents,
dit qu'il s'est senti désolé pour
son père vivant seul,
alors il a choisi d'y aller et
vivre avec son père.
Cela, il a appelé plus tard
une énorme erreur.
Il a déclaré officiellement :
il n'avait pas un super
relation avec son père.
Il en a notamment dit vraiment,
des choses vraiment difficiles
à propos de son père.
On dirait que c'était un
situation vraiment horrible.
Son père était ingénieur,
et Elon le dit souvent
de son sens de l'ingénierie
venait de son père,
et son père en avait
problèmes selon Elon,
mais ce qu'il avait
a été très incisif
formation d'ingénierie.
Aussi troublant que
La relation d'Elon
avec son père semblait être,
La relation d'Elon avec son
la mère a l'air d'être très bonne
et je suis parti de
force à force.
Je pense que sa mère est probablement
l'optimiste ultime.
Elle est charmante.
Elle est vraiment quelque chose.
Ouvrez le New York Times,
voilà Maye, c'est super.
j'ai été mannequin
depuis 50 ans, ah !
Donc, il vous suffit de
continue et sois gentil
et disponible, et soyez surpris
quand tu deviens soudainement
la mère de la mariée,
puis grand-mère.
La mère d'Elon a été
je le soutiens beaucoup
au cours des années.
Elle est constamment
franc sur Twitter
nous racontant les merveilles d'Elon,
et elle est clairement
très fier de lui.
Maye Musk est une
femme incroyable.
À quelque chose comme 69,
on l'appelle "Ça
Fille" de Vanity Fair.
C'est un modèle très demandé
qui fait des campagnes
pour les grandes marques
dans le monde entier.
Elle est l'une des plus
femmes âgées glamour
vous verrez jamais.
Malgré le fait qu'Elon
dit qu'il a essayé à plusieurs reprises,
Encore et encore et encore
pour essayer de réparer son
relation avec son père,
à ce stade, il est
je viens d'abandonner,
parce qu'il ne croit pas
son père est capable de changer.
Il a parlé ouvertement
sur comment, étant enfant
il passait beaucoup de temps seul.
Il dit qu'il s'en souvient encore
le bruit d'une maison vide,
des pas au loin
au loin,
et il n'a jamais
je voulais encore ça.
Mon propre point de vue est vraiment
des entrepreneurs stellaires,
leurs expériences de vie
surtout dans l'enfance
sont le déterminant de
leur succès plus tard.
Si vous regardez leurs débuts
expériences d'enfance,
tu trouveras un numéro
d’événements indésirables.
Événements indésirables importants
comme le harcèlement scolaire,
ou être rejeté.
Ces événements vous animent, vous
il faut maintenant prouver quelque chose.
Tu veux prendre le contrôle
d'un monde à nouveau,
tu n'avais pas le contrôle
de quand tu étais plus jeune,
et évoluer vers un poste de haut niveau,
être entrepreneur,
être PDG, cela vous donne du pouvoir,
te donne de la force,
vous donne le contrôle,
la chose qu'ils n'ont jamais eu
quand ils étaient plus jeunes,
donc je pense que c'est une conduite
force chez de nombreux entrepreneurs.
Elon Musk était présent
Lycée Bryanston
École à Pretoria,
où il a prospéré académiquement.
Il a eu une éducation assez difficile.
Il y a quelques rapports
également du harcèlement.
Vous savez, n'importe quel enfant qui
montre ce genre d'intellect,
et les intérêts pourraient tomber sous le coup
l'éclat des intimidateurs.
Il a même été hospitalisé
après un combat particulier.
C'était un nerd.
Il a été victime d'intimidation à l'école.
Il y avait un point où il était
même assommé.
Tu sais, ce n'était pas évident
qu'il était un commercial
génie à ce moment-là.
Elon a suivi des cours de lutte,
et un peu de judo dans un
tenter de compenser
avec un peu de physique supplémentaire,
et puis il a grandi
un peu,
j'ai eu une poussée de croissance,
je suis devenu un peu plus grand,
et j'ai vraiment pris le
les intimidateurs s'en prennent de front.
Après avoir dépensé
trois ans à Bryanston High,
Elon a assisté à Pretoria
Lycée pour garçons.
Elon a fréquenté Boys High
de 1986 à 1988,
quelle est l'année
il s'est inscrit.
Il excellait en sciences,
et il excellait aussi
en études informatiques.
En fait, il a obtenu un
distinction pour la science
et études informatiques en 1988.
Si je me souviens de ses notes,
parce que je les ai
dans mon carnet de notes,
et il était définitivement
premier de la classe de sciences.
J'en ai enseigné à beaucoup
les garçons au fil des années,
et Elon est resté dans mon esprit.
Tu sais, je ne peux pas le dire
toi où tous les garçons étaient assis,
mais je me souviens d'Elon
assis à l'arrière
de la classe
continuer son travail.
Il ne faisait pas partie des garçons
qui voulait de l'attention
tout le temps.
Nous prenons toujours beaucoup de
fierté pour tous les garçons,
mais d'un point de vue personnel
point de vue
ayant enseigné la science à Elon,
J'aimerais penser que
J'ai fait une petite contribution
dans ses années de formation.
j'ai lu serait
j'aimerais aller sur Mars.
J'espère qu'il le fera
ça beaucoup plus tôt,
mais à la manière de Star Trek donc
il peut m'y inviter.
Elon Musk
était toujours différent.
Son esprit d'entreprise
les entreprises ont commencé tôt.
En 1984, une science-fiction
succès technologique inspiré
a donné un indice sur son avenir
quand il a vendu son premier
logiciel commercial.
Il a commencé à travailler sur
ordinateurs à l'âge de 10 ans,
travaillant très dur,
et étant très intelligent
dans l'élaboration de programmes.
Il développe une vidéo
jeu appelé Blastar.
Il l'a vendu à
un magazine PC pour 500 $.
Elon a été interrogé sur
ce qui le distingue
d'autres personnes,
et il a lui-même dit :
il y avait des choses qui étaient
c'est très évident pour lui en grandissant
que d'autres personnes
je n'ai pas compris,
comment fonctionne la conduction,
comment font la lumière et les fils
un interrupteur s'allume,
des choses qui pour lui étaient
immédiatement clair et évident,
alors que d'autres personnes
ne s'est pas fait automatiquement,
surtout quand ils ont 14 ans,
comprendre ce qui se passait.
Il jouait beaucoup aux échecs,
et en conséquence c'était
toujours en quelque sorte anticiper.
Aux échecs, vous jouez à
pense qu'il va de l'avant.
Ainsi, même lorsqu'il était plus jeune,
il cherchait des idées pour
qu'est-ce qui pourrait faire du bien
affaires à court terme,
et puis qu'est-ce qui pourrait faire partie
d'un grand projet plus loin.
Après obtention du diplôme
du lycée,
Musk a brièvement assisté à la
Université de Prétoria
avant de décider de
quitter l'Afrique du Sud.
L'histoire d'Elon Musk
la richesse et son ascension
est lié en partie à
le rêve américain.
Cela lui a toujours été ancré
que l'Afrique du Sud n'était pas
où il allait atteindre
les ambitions qu'il avait.
Il voulait être en Amérique.
Il voulait être un
une partie de cette scène.
Au début, il ne pouvait pas
aller directement en Amérique.
Il devait en fait
passer par le Canada.
Elon a dépensé
deux ans d'études
à l'Université Queen's
en Ontario.
Il a financé ses propres diplômes
au Canada et aux États-Unis
en obtenant des bourses
et travaillant à temps partiel,
donc il n'avait pas un énorme
somme d'argent derrière lui.
Il a une université célèbre
papier où il parle de
vouloir conquérir différents
régions du monde,
et ceux inclus le
Internet, exploration spatiale,
énergie solaire,
intelligence artificielle,
et apprentissage cérébral
les interfaces également.
Ayant
diplômes complétés
en commerce et en physique,
en 1995, Musk a abandonné
le doctorat à Stanford
et se dirigea vers la Silicon Valley.
Il a laissé tomber
sorti de son troisième diplôme
à l'Université de Stanford à
Californie après seulement deux jours.
Et il avait lancé une entreprise
Avec son frère
Kimball a appelé Zip2,
et c'était effectivement un
formulaire de Pages Jaunes en ligne
qu'il a vendu à
journaux de l'époque.
Et il a eu de la chance quand
l'entreprise a été rachetée.
En fait, ils ont fini
le vendant à Compaq,
pour environ 307 millions de dollars,
alors qu'il n'avait que 27 ans.
Il a gagné environ 22 $
millions à l'époque,
ce qui est merveilleux,
énormément d'argent,
mais dans le style typique d'Elon,
il en a recyclé la moitié
dans sa prochaine aventure,
et qui finalement
a fini par devenir PayPal.
Ayant perturbé
le papier traditionnel
l'industrie de la publicité avec Zip2,
La prochaine entreprise de Musk a pris
le marché financier mondial.
X.com était censé être
un service financier complet
entreprise de services.
Donc, ça a l'air sympa
d'archaïque maintenant,
mais à l'époque
mettre ensemble
un service financier
suite sur internet
était une idée plutôt révolutionnaire.
Musc
était révolutionnaire
dans sa stratégie chez X.com,
offrir de nouveaux clients
récompenses en argent,
et créer du peer-to-peer
systèmes de paiement.
Mes premières impressions
c'était juste qu'il était
très concentré et très passionné
sur ce qu'il s'apprêtait à faire.
Cela semblait très clair au début
qu'Elon ne jouait pas par
le livre standard de la vie,
ou une entreprise, ou toute autre chose.
Alors, j'allais juste
soyez de la partie pour la balade.
Au début Elon
ce n'était pas du tout facile à lire,
surtout parce que tu
je n'en avais juste aucune idée
comment il allait
réagir à quoi que ce soit.
Je n'ai eu aucune expérience avec quelqu'un
qui pensait comme il l'a fait,
ou a parlé comme il l'a fait,
ou avait autant de confiance
à propos de ce qu'il faisait,
et en lui-même comme il l'a fait.
Cela m'était tellement étranger que
quelqu'un qui a grandi dans l'Iowa,
ou peut-être que c'est
étranger à tout le monde.
Je ne sais pas.
PayPal a été voté
un des 10 pires
idées commerciales en 1999.
Elon Musk a joué un rôle déterminant
dans l'accent mis par l'entreprise sur
un système de paiement mondial,
ce qui changerait le
cours d'Internet.
Les gens savent probablement
lui principalement de PayPal.
C'est à ce moment-là qu'il a vraiment commencé
est venu à la conscience publique.
PayPal était comment allons-nous
va transformer les finances
dans une transaction en ligne ?
Comment allons-nous rendre les choses faciles ?
Comment allons-nous faire
c'est plus efficace ?
Cela semble évident maintenant,
mais à l'époque les gens étaient encore
j'ai peur d'acheter des livres en ligne,
leur demandant donc de mettre tout leur
données financières en un seul endroit
n’était pas une proposition solide.
Le but de l'entreprise
que nous construisions
j'essayais toujours
faire quelque chose
très positif pour l'humanité,
et il pensait à
l'espace et les panneaux solaires,
et tout ça à l'époque.
Donc, nous savions que c'était
une sorte de tremplin
en route vers de plus grands rêves.
PayPal est rapidement devenu
le paiement en ligne
système de choix,
auprès de quelques milliers d'utilisateurs,
se multipliant à plus de
un million en quelques mois.
De personne à personne
côté paiement des choses
sommes partis si vite, nous étions
gagner du terrain comme un fou,
puis les enchères en ligne
le marché s'en est emparé,
et ça a explosé dans
cette chose énorme.
Nous ajoutions des dizaines de milliers
de nouveaux comptes chaque jour,
ce qui était à l'époque
assez inédit.
Elon a été très impliqué dans
tous les aspects de l'entreprise.
C'était son argent après tout
avec lequel nous jouions tous.
Alors, je pense que quand c'est ton
de l'argent sur la table, tu as,
c'est dans ton intérêt
être très impliqué
dans tous les détails.
Chaque jour était un nouveau
une sorte de feu, non ?
Quelque chose de tous les jours
brûlait
il fallait y remédier.
Nous avions un client
cauchemar de service
où peu de temps après
lancer le service,
nous en avions des milliers et des milliers
des emails dans la file d'attente,
parce que les gens
je n'ai pas compris,
encore une fois, le début
jours d'Internet,
ils n'ont pas compris comment
pour sortir leur argent.
Et donc, ils le feraient
paniquez et appelez,
ou email comme 12
des moments différents.
Nous avons donc deux millions
e-mails en attente
et nous n'en avions que 10
les gens du service client
dédié à gérer cela.
Et donc, nous n'en avions vraiment aucune idée
ce que nous allions faire.
Le service client était énormément
cher en Californie.
Et donc, j'ai dit tu sais
ça va paraître fou,
mais j'ai une énorme étendue
famille dans le Midwest.
Je pourrais tous les entraîner à
faire du service client à domicile.
Elon a d'abord ri, et
puis quelques heures plus tard
je suis revenu et j'ai tout dit
c'est vrai, monte dans un avion.
Alors, je suis sorti et j'ai enseigné
10 membres de ma famille
comment faire client
service à domicile,
et puis ma soeur
fini par embaucher
12 parents au foyer
une petite ville du Nebraska
qui a tout commencé
travailler à domicile.
Et ils étaient si bons
que nous avons fini par construire
un centre de service client
à Omaha, Nebraska,
qui emploie aujourd'hui 1800 personnes,
et cela s'est avéré fantastique.
Nous sommes passés de zéro à un
cent personnes en six semaines
à Omaha,
et c'était probablement le
chose la plus difficile,
mais nous étions un peu
à court d'options, donc.
Dirigé par son
passion pour le perfectionnisme,
détermination, et
une éthique de travail héroïque,
Musk a réussi sur les marchés
qui étaient auparavant considérés
impossible à conquérir.
Il a toujours eu plus haut
attentes pour lui-même
qu'il ne l'a fait pour les autres,
alors il s'est poussé
très, très dur.
Elon Musk est célèbre pour son
l'éthique du travail, qui est non-stop.
Je pense qu'il a deux modes,
et il y a un arrêt et un départ.
Il travaille 24 heures sur 24
et il attend tout le monde
sinon pour faire la même chose.
Elon était debout à toute heure
du travail de nuit.
Il enverrait des e-mails à
minuit ou 1h00 ou 2h00 du matin
et sois juste très
concentré sur un problème
que nous essayions de résoudre.
Si vous entendez des histoires de
SpaceX à ses débuts,
les gens avaient vraiment du mal
pour suivre son rythme,
mais c'est comme ça qu'il travaille,
et si tu ne peux pas garder
rythme, tu es dehors.
Je pensais que c'était un bon patron.
C'est un peu tristement célèbre maintenant
qu'il traverse
Les gens des relations publiques très rapidement,
mais à ce moment-là, je pensais
J'allais juste dire,
une personne normale en relations publiques.
Et donc, Elon n'était pas vraiment
je vais avoir tout ça.
Il attendait beaucoup de son peuple,
mais nous nous attendions tous
beaucoup les uns des autres,
et c'est comme ça que vous y parvenez.
Dans la culture des startups
l'attente est
que tout le monde est
travailler tout le temps.
Vous arrivez à 9h00
ou 10h00 du matin
et ne pas partir
jusqu'à 9h00 ou 10h00
ou peut-être après ça la nuit.
Et Elon travaillait définitivement
jusqu'à minuit tous les soirs.
C'était exactement ce que nous
je l'ai fait, et c'était excitant.
Rarement quelqu'un s'est plaint
à propos de ce genre de chose,
parce que tu avais vraiment l'impression
tu étais en train de changer le monde.
Alors que PayPal prospérait,
Les problèmes au sein des conseils d’administration tenaient Musk.
Un désaccord interne
avec le Conseil
a permis à Elon d'être
évincé de sa propre entreprise.
Il fût un temps
quand Pierre Theil
et Elon étaient co-PDG de PayPal,
mais il y avait certains
divergences d'opinion
sur la technologie et
l'image de marque de l'entreprise
qui a conduit au vote non
confiance pour évincer Elon.
Et Elon malheureusement,
était en Afrique du Sud.
je venais de parler avec
lui au téléphone ce jour-là,
et il dit à quel point c'est grave ?
Je me dis oh, ce n'est pas si mal.
Et puis cette nuit-là, je suis allé
à la maison, et j'étais allongé dans mon lit,
et j'ai commencé à réaliser et
commencé à rassembler
tous les morceaux de qui je
j'avais vu au bureau,
et que se passait-il,
et vers 22h30
Je me suis assis droit dans le lit,
et je suis sûr d'en avoir dit
gros mot au plafond.
Je me suis levé et je suis parti
de retour au bureau,
et bien sûr
tout le monde était là,
et c'était à ce moment-là
ils le faisaient.
Ils parlaient à
le Conseil au téléphone,
et l'évincer, et je
j'ai essayé d'appeler Elon,
et il était dans un avion,
et je n'ai pas pu l'avoir.
Je n'ai pas pu l'avoir
jusqu'au matin,
et à ce moment-là, c'était aussi le cas
tard, c'était déjà fait.
Je suis sûr qu'il y a eu pas mal de
un peu de malheur au début,
mais il a vraiment géré
c'est à merveille.
Musk a quitté PayPal,
mais en tant que principal actionnaire,
est resté dans un rôle consultatif.
Sa prochaine aubaine
arrivé en 2002,
quand eBay a acheté PayPal,
le laissant riche
au-delà de la croyance.
C'est là qu'Elon
commencé à faire
un peu d'argent sérieux.
Il a encaissé environ
165 millions de dollars merveilleux.
Ce qui était incroyable, c'est qu'il
j'ai presque tout labouré
dans ces nouveaux
entreprises commerciales.
Il n'en a pas mis
à part pour lui-même,
je n'ai pas pensé à quoi
de gain personnel,
à court terme du moins.
- Il a pris 100 millions de dollars
et mettez-le dans SpaceX,
70 millions de dollars terminés
aller chez Tesla,
et environ 10 millions de dollars
aller à SolarCity.
La plupart des gens le feraient
disons 165 millions de dollars,
Je suis prêt pour la vie.
Ça y est, où est la plage ?
Allons-y.
Pas Elon, et j'ai un
beaucoup de respect pour ça.
Mesdames et Messieurs,
veuillez accueillir Elon Musk.
En 2001,
Elon établi
la Fondation Musk,
fournir de l'énergie solaire
systèmes vers des régions du monde
frappés par des catastrophes naturelles.
Il s'est également engagé à donner
au moins la moitié de son
la richesse à la philanthropie.
Beaucoup de gens pensent
que les entrepreneurs
sont motivés par l'argent,
et c'est pourquoi ils sont
entrepreneurs en série.
Ils veulent gagner de plus en plus.
Vraiment après toi
gagner 50 millions de dollars,
tu as besoin de gagner plus d'argent ?
Pas vraiment, c'est
pas un bon conducteur.
Ils ne sont pas conduits
par l'argent du tout.
Il en est sans doute conscient.
Si tu as 20 $
milliards flottant autour,
Je suis sûr que tu l'aurais remarqué,
mais je ne pense pas que ce soit
le principal moteur pour lui.
Vraiment pas.
Je pense qu'il a
une vision plus grande,
au-delà de ce petit
chose appelée argent,
mais l'argent l'aide
exécuter le rêve,
c'est donc une chose nécessaire.
Ce n'est certainement pas la poursuite
d'argent à ce stade.
Je pense qu'il a réalisé que nous sommes là,
et c'est plus
intéressant de passer du temps
faire quelque chose que tu trouves
significatif dans ton cœur,
et c'est ce qu'il fait.
C'est presque comme une drogue.
Quand tu en as fait un
chose réussie,
tu veux l'autre,
tu veux inventer un nouveau
vision et continuer à apprendre.
C'est juste une façon d'être.
Il s'ennuierait sur la plage.
Ce doit être un très
grand objectif de changement du monde
pour qu'il se lève
le matin.
C'est juste comme ça qu'il est câblé.
Donc, je ne m'attends pas à ce que cela s'arrête.
Je pense que c'est en fait
va faire
une différence pour le monde
si nous passons à
transport durable
plutôt tôt que tard.
Nous ne faisons pas ça parce que
nous pensions que c'était comme
un moyen de devenir riche ou quoi que ce soit.
Comme je l'ai dit, je pensais que peut-être
une chance de 10 pour cent de
succès au début.
Je pensais que j'allais perdre
tout mon argent, et j'ai failli le faire.
Donc, ce n'est pas comme avant,
Je me suis approché très près de
perdre tout.
Faucon 9
a dégagé la tour.
Ayant
conquis le cyberespace,
La prochaine mission de Musk serait
se concentrer sur l’espace.
En 2002, il en a lancé un
des plus révolutionnaires
les entreprises de notre temps,
concentré sur le bouleversement
l'industrie spatiale.
La percée cruciale
c'est nécessaire
rendre la vie multiplanétaire, c'est
un pleinement et rapidement
fusée de classe orbite réutilisable.
C'est un très
chose difficile à faire,
parce que nous vivons sur une planète,
où c'est juste
à peine possible.
Au cours des 12 derniers mois environ,
je suis arrivé à la conclusion
que cela peut être résolu,
et je pense que SpaceX est
je vais essayer de le faire.
Nous pourrions échouer.
Je ne dis pas que nous le sommes
certain du succès ici,
mais nous y allons
pour essayer de le faire.
Personne ne pensait qu'il
pourrait faire ce qu'il a fait
quand il est parti pour la première fois
pour atteindre ses objectifs.
Je veux dire ce Sud-Africain aléatoire
arrivé dans les années 2000
et disant qu'il veut
construire une fusée
qui peut atterrir tout seul
de retour au sol,
peut mettre des choses en orbite
pour 10 fois moins cher
que quiconque.
On s'est moqué de lui
de la place dans la plupart des endroits.
Ils en quelque sorte
l'a ignoré au début
et puis il est gentil
de mettre son argent
où se trouvait littéralement sa bouche.
Il est allé en Russie une fois
pour essayer d'en acheter
moteurs de fusée hors d'eux,
et il s'est moqué
du pays essentiellement
par leurs ingénieurs,
alors il est revenu aux États-Unis
et il a construit sa propre fusée.
Nous étions encore habitués à
NASA, l'espace est égal à la NASA,
mais quand Elon Musk
commencé à expérimenter
avec ces nouvelles fusées,
nous avons réalisé que
Elon Musk et SpaceX
est un acteur spatial sérieux.
Tout
ça a l'air bien
pour le début de
les tâches de marche dans l'espace d'aujourd'hui.
Les trois premiers
Les lancements de SpaceX ont échoué,
ce qui a suscité le scepticisme
chez de nombreux investisseurs.
Le
véhicule en route sur la bonne voie.
Et il semble que nous ayons eu
une panne de lanceur.
Juste un an
après avoir fondé SpaceX,
Musk a investi dans Tesla Motors,
un constructeur de voitures électriques
visant à produire un
une voiture puissante et zéro polluante.
Au cours des prochaines années,
Tesla prendrait le
leader sur un marché de niche.
Notre objectif était de vraiment
essayer de créer
la meilleure voiture du monde
afin de montrer que
une voiture électrique peut être
la meilleure voiture du monde.
Parce que beaucoup de gens
avoir cette perception que
les voitures électriques sont compromises,
qu'il y a des problèmes
avec les voitures électriques,
et puis si vous achetez de l'électrique,
c'est parce que tu en as
une sorte de fétichisme électrique.
Ce que je pense est
incroyablement important
c'est briser cette perception
et montre qu'en effet
la voiture électrique peut être
mieux que n'importe quelle voiture à essence.
Si tu regardes la révolution
c'est presque arrivé
nous dans des voitures électriques,
Tesla était là en premier.
- Il y a eu
diverses tentatives
apporter de l'électricité
les voitures qui sont tombées en panne,
parce que les grands géants de l'automobile
je ne voulais pas qu'ils réussissent.
Elon ne savait rien
sur les voitures électriques
quand il a commencé,
mais j'ai reconnu que
il y avait un problème là
qui devait être résolu,
et il vient de passer au bulldozer
son chemin à travers cela.
Je suis vraiment excité par
le fait que nous avons
une voiture de sport zéro émission
ça peut s'affronter
avec une Ferrari et
une Porsche et gagner.
C'est ce qui est vraiment perturbateur,
un technicien arrive
dans l'espace de la voiture.
Elon ne regarde pas
comme une voiture.
C'est un logiciel
avec un peu de
matériel qui y est attaché.
La conduite
expérience dans une Tesla,
tout le monde en raffole.
C'est rapide, c'est silencieux,
mais aussi avec les Tesla
c'est la technologie,
le fait qu'ils
se mettre à jour.
J'ai eu une Tesla pendant un moment et
Je sortirai demain matin.
Mise à jour logicielle
comme le fait votre téléphone
et tu mets des trucs sur ta voiture
que tu n'avais pas
la nuit précédente.
Vous pouvez réellement déplacer votre
Tesla hors d'une place de parking
avec votre smartphone.
Donc c'est tout simplement incroyable.
Pour quelqu'un qui est un
fan de voiture et fan de technologie.
France, Royaume-Uni,
qui disent qu'ils vont
interdire la vente de voitures à essence
dans les 10 ou 20 prochaines années,
et c'est joli
un grand merci à Tesla.
Face à massivement
baisse des prix du pétrole
Je pense que c'est en fait
devient plus urgent
que l'automobile fabrique
transition vers l'électrique
et j'ai déployé énormément d'efforts
derrière leur électrique
programmes de véhicules.
Ce qui est étonnant, c'est la façon dont
reste de l'industrie automobile
est en quelque sorte à suivre.
Ils avaient ce lithium-ion
technologie cellulaire
que d'autres entreprises
ne pouvait vraiment pas correspondre.
- Il n'y a pas de voiture
entreprise dans le monde
qui ne regarde pas
un véhicule électrique.
Il n'y a probablement pas de
constructeur automobile dans le monde
qui n'a pas démonté une Tesla
pour voir ce qui se passe
en dessous.
Chez Tesla, nous avons ouvert
d'origine nos brevets,
donc nous essayons d'être
aussi utile que possible
pour l'avènement de
véhicules électriques
et nous l'avons également dit
notre réseau super recharge,
nous sommes heureux d'en avoir d'autres
les constructeurs automobiles utilisent ce réseau.
Nous faisons vraiment
faire tout ce que nous pouvons
pour accélérer l'avènement
de voitures durables.
Je veux dire, maintenant nous le savons
GM et Land Rover ont déclaré
ils vont commencer
faire des voitures électriques
dans le futur proche,
juste des voitures électriques.
Il y a tellement de choses
que Tesla a fait en premier,
qui a tous les autres
constructeur automobile à travers la planète
je regarde, je pense ouais,
nous devons faire comme
ce n'est pas le cas ?
Le problème fondamental
sont les règles aujourd'hui
inciter les gens à créer du carbone,
et c'est de la folie, et
tout ce que vous encouragez arrivera.
Nous devons envoyer un message clair
aux équipes de négociation
et aux hommes politiques
que cette fois
il doit y avoir
changement significatif.
Une pièce essentielle
du récit de triomphe d'Elon Musk
c'est à quel point il s'est approché
pour achever le désastre.
De son propre aveu, 2008 a été
la pire année de sa vie.
Ses entreprises ont été battues
par la crise économique.
Il reste trois lancements ratés
SpaceX en jeu,
et Tesla était sur le
au bord de la faillite.
Elon était largement
supposé terminé.
Il y en avait un million
endroits le long du chemin
où il aurait pu
arrêté ou déraillé
ou j'ai décidé d'aller l'acheter
île et asseyez-vous dessus,
mais il ne l'a pas fait.
Ce sont des preneurs de risques,
ils l'adorent.
Ils vivent pour être
sur le fil du couteau.
L’échec est attendu.
Les entrepreneurs ne le font pas
s'attendre nécessairement
pour réussir tout le temps,
ce qui est une caractéristique
c'est ce qui fait leur succès,
parce que quand ils échouent,
et tous les entrepreneurs le font
parce qu'ils prennent des risques,
ils l'effacent simplement.
Ils ont ce phénoménal
facteur de rebond.
Contrairement à d'autres personnes qui obtiennent
absorbé par l'échec,
et reste bloqué,
et ils ne peuvent pas faire
autre chose pendant un moment,
il peut faire face à l'échec.
Et pour pouvoir rebondir,
puis va dans un autre
s'aventurer sans cligner des yeux
c'est de ça qu'il s'agit.
Avec ses entreprises
au bord de l'effondrement,
le malheur a été évité
à la dernière minute.
Tesla a été sauvée par les investisseurs
et SpaceX a reçu un
Contrat de 1,6 milliard de dollars avec la NASA.
L'équipe SpaceX est incroyable.
Ils sont vraiment
repousser les limites
en ce qui concerne où nous allons
en avant avec l’exploration.
Je pense que les humains sont
naturellement poussé à le faire,
et c'est vraiment
le début je pense
d'êtres humains quittant
orbite terrestre basse.
J'ai certainement l'intention de
être là pour voir ça.
En 2010, Elon a lancé
son vaisseau spatial Dragon
à l'Internationale
Station spatiale.
SpaceX est devenue la première entreprise
accoster un privé
vaisseau spatial avec l'ISS,
ce qui était étonnant à l’époque.
C'est Mission
Contrôle, Houston,
heure officielle d'ouverture des écoutilles
pour le SpaceX
Vaisseau spatial Dragon.
Chaque parcelle d'adrénaline dans mon
corps libéré à ce moment-là.
C'est tellement extrêmement
moment intense.
Tout aurait pu mal tourner,
et tout s'est passé
c'est vrai, heureusement,
alors je me suis senti, je me sens très chanceux.
Don Pettit donnant
le pouce en l'air,
ainsi que le reste de l'équipage.
Elon Musk développe
un palmarès
de livrer
ce qu'il dit, il le fera.
Donc il a déjà
développé des fusées réutilisables.
Il fournit
la station spatiale.
La prochaine étape sera
être d'avoir des versions
de son vaisseau spatial Dragon
qui sont évalués par les humains.
Donc, il est en fait
tenir sa promesse.
Au dessus de
les prochaines années,
Tesla prendrait les devants
sur le marché des voitures électriques.
Sous la direction d'Elon,
l'entreprise est saluée
comme le grand américain
industrie automobile
histoire de réussite du siècle.
Tesla célèbre
ne fait pas de publicité.
Je ne pense pas que ce soit nécessaire.
Il y a un tel buzz
sur la marque.
Les choses allaient
suivre pour pouvoir
découvrez le modèle 3
calendrier de production
au milieu de l'année prochaine,
et vraiment excité
sur ce qui se passe.
La valeur de Tesla est quelque chose
ça a beaucoup de monde
se gratter la tête,
le fait que c'est une entreprise
ça ne rapporte pas d'argent,
mais pourtant, cela a une valeur énorme.
La réputation de Tesla en tant que
beaucoup à voir avec le produit
comme le gars qui est
diriger l'entreprise.
Franchement, si les voitures
n'était pas bon
les gens ne les achèteraient pas,
mais ils sont bons, ils
sont des leaders technologiques,
et c'est vraiment ça
obtient ce qui suit.
Le fait qu'il y ait
un gars comme Elon
diriger également l'entreprise
c'est la cerise sur le gâteau.
Le public général
vraiment apprécié
ce genre d'approche franche
à la façon dont il court
ses entreprises.
Si les gens veulent
les voitures électriques, très bien,
mais tu vois à travers
les voitures électriques, ça vient quoi ?
Voitures sans conducteur.
Maintenant, quand tu vois
certaines des choses
ce qui s'est passé
avec des voitures sans conducteur
et tu vois comment les ordinateurs
ça peut mal tourner, eh bien tu sais,
Je ne suis pas sûr de vouloir
être dans une voiture sans conducteur.
Les gens sont assez dérangés
sur l'ensemble
chose de véhicule autonome.
Je pense que peut-être que les gens ont
cette image semblable à celle semblable,
les voitures robotisées se déchaînent.
Ce n'est vraiment pas
quelque chose comme ça.
Tout cela s'appliquerait à,
le logiciel passe par
niveaux de validation extrêmes
avant qu'un client ne le voie.
Donc, il y a tout
des sortes de bêtises
à propos des personnes utilisées
comme cobayes humains.
Tu sais, c'est fondamentalement
conducteur avancé
assistance à ce stade,
et en fait nous utilisons
le nom Pilote automatique,
parce que c'est ce que c'est
ce qui est utilisé dans un avion,
mais la présomption dans les avions
c'est que le pilote doit,
tu sais, paye
attention et soyez vigilant
et sois prêt à prendre
à tout moment,
non pas que le pilote puisse
alors va, va dormir,
ou tu sais, éloigne-toi
depuis le cockpit.
Musk affronte
certains des mondes
les plus grands défis à relever.
A travers Tesla, il entend
réduire notre consommation d'énergies fossiles,
tout en simultané
tenter de révolutionner
l'industrie de l'énergie.
Un élément clé de son objectif
c'est changer non seulement
consommation d'énergie,
mais la production d'énergie.
Elon est le président
de SolarCity,
l'un des plus grands producteurs de
systèmes d'énergie solaire aux États-Unis.
Les gens dans un village isolé
ou une île quelque part
peut prendre des panneaux solaires, combiner
avec le Tesla Powerwall
et je n'aurai jamais à m'inquiéter
avoir des lignes électriques.
Les lignes électriques ne sont pas
la plus jolie
chose au monde.
Alors, pouvoir
j'ai cette solution
fonctionne où que vous soyez.
Le fait que c'est
le montage mural est vital,
parce que ça veut dire que tu ne le fais pas
besoin d'avoir une salle de batterie.
Cela signifie qu'une normale
la maison peut monter ceci
dans leur garage ou sur le
mur extérieur de leur maison
et ça ne prend pas de place.
Tu pourrais en fait y aller si tu
veulent complètement hors réseau.
Vous pouvez emporter vos panneaux solaires,
charger les batteries,
et c'est tout ce que tu utilises et
le coût est de 3 500 $.
Avec la société SolarCity
qui fait désormais partie de Tesla.
Elon essaie de
fabriquer des panneaux solaires
plus attrayant pour
le marché de masse.
Ils ont lancé leur nouveau
technologie de toit solaire,
alors qu'autrefois
des panneaux solaires seraient
grands carrés noirs et volumineux
que tu aurais mis
votre toit ou votre jardin.
Maintenant, les gens vont
avoir des panneaux solaires
encastrés dans leur toit.
Tesla
Batterie aux ions lithium
installé en Australie du Sud,
conduit à un énorme
baisse du coût
de sauvegarder le
l'alimentation électrique de la région.
Le système alimenté
par les éoliennes
réduit le prix de l'électricité
pannes de 90 pour cent.
Ils prennent le
surplus d'électricité
qui est en train d'être produit
en Australie,
et le stocker et mettre
il revient à la grille.
Je pense que leur dernier
l'estimation suggère
ils se rattrapent
millions de dollars par jour
dans l'électricité
ils stockent,
ce qui est assez impressionnant.
Cela venait d'un pari que
il a fait sur Twitter.
C'était donc un
Homme d'affaires australien,
et ils discutaient
sur la faisabilité
de faire une ville
fonctionner à l’énergie solaire.
Et un pari était
délivré à Musk à propos de
peux-tu faire ça
dans autant de temps,
et il est parti, je prends ce pari.
Il a mis les piles en place,
il était opérationnel
dans les délais,
tout ça pour le pari d'un milliardaire
et c'est ce qui en est arrivé.
Nous sommes parvenus à un accord
avec Tesla Motor Company
soumis aux dispositions législatives
examen et approbation,
qui permettra à Tesla de
construire le plus grand du monde
et le plus avancé
usine de batteries,
ici même dans le Silver State.
Pourquoi appelons-nous même
c'est la Gigafactory ?
C'est parce que c'est
ça va en fait,
ça ne sera pas juste
le plus gros lithium-ion
usine de batteries dans le monde,
mais ce sera en fait
être plus grand que la somme
de tous les lithium-ion
usines dans le monde.
Il est donc difficile de
décrire tout à fait avec des mots,
mais c'est un putain
d'une grande usine.
Depuis
le lancement du Dragon,
Elon Musk a continué à
entrez dans l'histoire avec SpaceX.
Quand la fusée Falcon Heavy
lancé en février 2018,
ça annonçait le début
d'une nouvelle course à l'espace.
Elon Musk et son
l'équipe vient de prouver
que le Falcon Heavy fonctionne,
ce qui nous met maintenant dans une
un domaine complètement différent,
ce que nous pouvons mettre dans l'espace lointain,
ce que nous pouvons envoyer sur Mars.
Décollage
depuis la même rampe de lancement
qui a envoyé l'équipage de
Apollo 11 vers la lune,
la mission
représentait une nouvelle ère
au cours du vol spatial.
Le lancement du
SpaceX Falcon Lourd,
c'était important pour ça
de nombreuses raisons scientifiques.
Je veux dire, c'est le plus puissant
fusée que nous avons vue lancée
depuis le Saturne V, qui
a emmené les humains sur la lune.
C'est un
petit pas pour l'homme,
un pas de géant pour l'humanité.
Nous entrons dans une nouvelle
l'ère de l'exploration spatiale,
ce qui est extrêmement excitant.
Une sorte de continuation
du rêve d'Apollon.
J'étais sur l'Espace
Côte pour le lancement.
je ne l'ai pas vu ça
occupé là-bas depuis 2011
quand la navette spatiale a décollé
et atterri pour la dernière fois.
Cela a vraiment commencé à
capturer l'imagination des gens
sur l'exploration spatiale.
C'était une grande réussite
par une entreprise privée
créer et
lancer avec succès
l'un des plus gros levages
fusées de tous les temps dans l'histoire.
C'est le troisième plus grand
fusée jamais lancée.
Nous avions l'Apollo Saturn V,
et bien sûr nous
avait la navette.
Le Falcon Heavy est
cet ordre de grandeur.
C’est une très grosse fusée.
Le faucon lourd
peut transporter 64 tonnes.
C'est beaucoup, je
ça veut dire que c'est un camion.
C'est l'équivalent
d'un avion de ligne 737,
rempli de passagers,
rempli de bagages,
rempli de carburant,
soulever ça et
l'envoyer dans l'espace,
et pas seulement l'envoi
dans l'espace,
l'envoyer au-delà
orbite terrestre basse,
l'envoyant au-delà de la lune,
l'envoyer au-delà de Mars.
Ce lancement aura également
implications politiques
à mon avis,
parce que l'Américain
le gouvernement se prépare
et la budgétisation pour
Les fusées de la NASA,
mais le fait qu'Elon
et SpaceX ont maintenant prouvé
ils peuvent réussir
lancer le Falcon Heavy,
qui aura probablement un
coût d'environ 100 millions de dollars,
cela représente environ 10 % de
les fusées de la NASA,
donc ils budgétisent environ
un milliard de dollars par lancement.
Cela représente une économie importante.
Pour que nous puissions vraiment
ouvrir l'accès à l'espace
nous devons atteindre pleinement
et une réutilisation rapide.
De tout
Les innovations de Musk
développer des fusées réutilisables
pourrait être le plus radical.
Nous pensions que c'était
plus probable qu'improbable
que cette mission fonctionnerait,
mais c'est quand même probablement, tu sais
une troisième chance d'échec.
Le Saint Graal pour l'espace
c'est d'avoir un totalement
système de lancement réutilisable.
Donc, pour voir réellement le
Fusées SpaceX Falcon
lancer son
vaisseau spatial en orbite
et puis redescendre
et effectuer un
localiser un atterrissage précis
sur une plateforme flottante en mer,
c'est assez étonnant.
Quand tu montes dans un avion
et tu voles quelque part,
tu ne rêverais pas
jeter cet avion,
alors pourquoi faisons-nous le
pareil avec les fusées spatiales ?
C'est ce que SpaceX essaie
faire et ils réussissent.
Ils mènent le
façon pour le moment.
Elon obtient
des gens à interroger
pourquoi la NASA continue de construire
aucune fusée du tout.
Ils pensent que si SpaceX peut le faire,
pourquoi devons-nous acheter
une fusée comparable ?
Nous pouvons simplement acheter
celui-là d'eux.
À l’intérieur du Falcon Heavy
la fusée était une plaque
avec 6 000 noms de tous
les employés de SpaceX
qui a travaillé sur le projet,
et ça montre juste
qu'il est prêt à
valorise vraiment les gens
ça marche pour lui.
Les aspirations d'Elon Musk
c'est à terme
mettre tous ses efforts
en développement
des fusées bien plus grosses,
qui peut encore lancer
charges utiles en orbite terrestre,
mais aussi être capable de
prendre un vaisseau spatial évalué par les humains
dans l'espace profond, c'est-à-dire Mars.
Je veux activer grand
nombre de personnes
et du fret pour aller sur Mars.
Donc, ce n'est pas en quelque sorte
à propos de moi personnellement
je veux faire un
voyage de retour sur Mars,
Je veux dire, ce serait
sympa sur le plan personnel,
mais je pense que c'est important
que nous, en tant qu'espèce
de cette civilisation
sont en passe de devenir un
véritable civilisation classée dans l'espace
et une espèce multi-planétaire.
Musk a l'intention de lancer
une mission sur Mars d’ici 2022.
L'ultime d'Elon Musk
le but est d'avoir des humains
vivre en permanence
et travailler sur Mars,
une colonie martienne pourrait-on dire.
Mars est très spécial.
Il a un ciel et
il y a du paysage
et de grandes quantités de produits congelés
l'eau et il y a des saisons,
donc il y en a beaucoup
similitudes avec la Terre.
L'atmosphère est beaucoup plus mince
que l'atmosphère terrestre,
mais tu as du carbone et
alors tu as de l'oxygène,
donc vous pourriez potentiellement utiliser
qu'y a-t-il sur Mars
atmosphère comme ressources.
C'est un très terrestre
environnement.
Il semble que ce soit une maison
de chez moi, mais est-ce le cas ?
C'est possible de notre vivant
envoyer une fusée
vers Mars, habité,
Je pense que c'est possible.
Voulons-nous le faire ?
Voulons-nous payer pour cela ?
C'est une autre question.
Il y a beaucoup de questions,
il y a beaucoup d'obstacles,
mais tant que
Elon ne casse pas
les lois fondamentales de
en physique, nous pouvons le faire.
Mars est accessible et je suis
bien sûr, nous trouverons les moyens
grâce auquel nous pouvons y vivre,
mais il y en a beaucoup
questions et défis
avant que cela puisse être réalisé.
Alors laissez Musk dire
il va le faire,
parce qu'il le fera probablement.
S'il maintient cela
élan, je ne vois aucune raison
pourquoi il ne devrait pas atterrir
vaisseaux spatiaux sur Mars.
Celui d'Elon Musk
évolution avec le design,
ingénierie et critique
décisions techniques
est unique parmi ses pairs.
Croyez-moi, Elon est juste
aussi intelligent en ingénierie
comme il est du côté de l'argent.
Même au début
jours de Tesla et SpaceX
il aurait facilement pu dire,
laisse-moi en mettre un peu
de mon argent là-dedans,
et nous en mettrons
des techniciens intelligents,
et je vais juste l'exécuter,
Je serai le manager,
Je serai le PDG ou
peu importe, euh-euhn.
Pour pouvoir réellement
pour s'impliquer autant
dans l'ingénierie
côté, c'est incroyable,
mais c'est ce qu'il a fait,
parce qu'au fond
il est ingénieur.
Je dirais qu'il s'approche
ingénierie et affaires
à peu près de la même manière,
c'est un puzzle à disséquer,
et puis les morceaux mis
se remettre ensemble d'une manière ou d'une autre.
En son cœur, le
l'homme est ingénieur.
Je pense que c'est là
c'est son premier amour.
Il se promènera dans SpaceX,
et parlera aux employés,
puis je les interrogerai sur
des choses comme les vecteurs de poussée
ou conception aérodynamique,
ce n’est pas typique du comportement d’un PDG.
Certains entrepreneurs sont plus
socialement qualifié que les autres,
mais ils ne le sont pas nécessairement
socialement compétent,
parce qu'ils sont trop concentrés.
Vous voyez, si vous êtes un
être humain socialement compétent,
alors tu es sensible
à tout le monde autour de toi,
mais ça peut t'empêcher
de réellement s'entendre
pour atteindre votre objectif,
et ils ont
objectifs en tête,
et ils sont
impitoyable dans le sens
d'essayer d'atteindre
cet objectif.
Pas impitoyable dans leur façon
traiter les autres nécessairement,
juste pour m'assurer que
ils sont sur leur propre calendrier
pour atteindre cet objectif.
Musk continue
pour investir dans l'avenir.
En 2013, il a présenté un
plan potentiel pour changer le monde
pour un système de transport
qui pourrait remodeler le
la façon dont l'humanité voyage.
Elon Musk a eu une idée.
Il a publié un livre blanc
sur ce transport sous vide,
mais laisse tomber.
Il a dit que je ne le suis pas
je vais le faire moi-même.
Ce que je vais faire, c'est ouvrir
jusqu'aux sociétés tierces
qui veulent développer
cela eux-mêmes.
Le projet Hyperloop
est d'un grand intérêt
en termes de monde
du transport,
l'idée de partir de San
Francisco à Los Angeles
dans le temps
il faudrait pour conduire
de San Francisco au
la périphérie de San Francisco est fantastique.
C'est un tube à vide,
où tout l'air
est aspiré hors du
tube, et tu envoies un pod
contenant des passagers
à travers le tube.
Il n'y a pas de friction,
il n'y a pas de résistance à l'air,
parce que les dosettes sont
en lévitation sur des aimants.
- La technologie est solide.
Nous pouvons voyager plus vite dans un
le vide, il n'y a pas de friction.
Ils veulent prendre de la vitesse
environ 500 à 700 miles par heure.
L'idée d'Elon est que les tubes
pourrait relier les grandes villes,
et tu pourrais voyager dans
un de ces modules de passagers
et voyager depuis, disons,
De Los Angeles à New York
en une demi-heure.
Nous déplacerons des marchandises en 2019.
Nous pensons que nous pouvons avoir des passagers
être transporté en toute sécurité
en Hyperloop d’ici 2021.
Elon Musk
est une voix de premier plan
sur le potentiel de
une apocalypse de l'IA.
Il a déclaré que
super intelligence numérique
est la menace la plus sérieuse
à la survie
de la race humaine.
Pour compenser cela, il
a lancé Neuralink,
visant à développer des
et bénéfique
intelligence artificielle.
Les dangers de l'IA,
sont la fin de l'humain
l'esprit tel que nous le connaissons.
Vous avez affaire à quelque chose
cela va fondamentalement
être plus intelligent que toi.
Il va apprendre tout seul,
alors comment garder une longueur d'avance ?
C'est quelque chose que Musk
y prête une attention particulière.
Sa principale préoccupation est que,
si l'IA devient trop intelligente
et trop important,
alors pourquoi as-tu besoin d'humains ?
Nous devenons en quelque sorte obsolètes.
Le pire cauchemar
c'est une horreur hollywoodienne
un film pourrait proposer
n'est rien comparé
vers où nous allons
et je vais si vite.
Quand l'IA a le
capacité de penser,
tirer des conclusions, et
porter des jugements, et cetera,
tout comme l'esprit humain,
est-ce que quelqu'un pense qu'il pourrait
sois juste la moindre chance
que grâce à cela seul, l'IA
pourrait-il prendre le contrôle de la planète ?
S'ils prennent conscience d'eux-mêmes,
comment allons-nous les contrôler ?
Qui va contrôler
les contrôleurs ?
C'est une perspective effrayante.
Quel est son potentiel
tout reprendre ?
Vous savez quel est son potentiel
tout reprendre, c'est ?
100 pour cent, c'est
la fin de l'humanité.
Quand le logiciel s'élève
et devient tout puissant,
où allons-nous regarder ?
Nous allons regarder
les titans de l'industrie
pour fournir un contrepoids.
Elon est idéalement placé pour
être une sorte de contrepoint
à ce logiciel de vision précoce.
Je veux dire, c'est intéressant
qu'il cherche aussi
dans l'IA lui-même
avec IA ouverte et Neuralink.
Quand j'entends Elon Musk
parler du fait
que la révolution de l'IA est
l'humanité invoquant le démon,
c'est absolument le cas,
mais ensuite fonder et ouvrir
société appelée Neuralink
pour connecter l'IA à
le cerveau humain.
Je veux dire cette contradiction
est tellement extraordinaire,
je ne connais pas le
processus de pensée
ça doit se passer là-bas.
Neuralink est une réponse directe
des préoccupations d'Elon à
L’IA en premier lieu.
Le fait qu'il pense
L’IA pourrait surpasser les humains
en termes de son
capacités mentales,
il est logique qu'il le fasse
essayer de développer la technologie
utiliser des ordinateurs dans
en tandem avec notre biologie.
Je pense qu'Elon
Musk veut utiliser l'IA
comme un outil pour
augmenter notre moi,
et pas un outil pour
remplacer notre moi.
Je pense qu'il dit si
tu ne peux pas les battre,
devenir surhumain
puis battez-les.
Interfaces cerveau-ordinateur
pourrait aider les gens
de deux manières différentes.
Donc, une façon serait
pour restaurer les capacités
pour les personnes handicapées,
et une autre application serait
être d'aller au-delà de nos limites.
Et donc, par exemple
nous pourrions penser
à propos du contrôle d'un ordinateur
juste avec nos pensées
sans bouger aucun muscle,
et c'est le noyau
fonction d'un BCI,
une interface cerveau-ordinateur.
Il y a beaucoup de
différents scénarios
dans lequel vous pourriez
appliquer cette technologie.
Nous parlons de critique
prise de décision dans l'armée,
dans un scénario de guerre,
ou dans le secteur de la santé.
Alors, chaque fois que nous parlons
sur les humains hybrides,
ou humain et
machine, ou cyborgs,
nous parlons tous de
la même chose je pense,
qui utilise la technologie
pour augmenter nos capacités
et c'est tout.
Le scepticisme de Musk
sur le potentiel
risques de la technologie IA
a conduit à un affrontement public
avec Mark Zuckerberg.
je suis optimiste quant à
l'avenir de l'IA.
Je pense que l'IA
va débloquer
une énorme quantité de
choses positives,
si cela aide à
identifier et guérir les maladies,
pour aider les voitures à conduire de manière plus sûre,
pour aider à garder notre
communautés sûres,
est-ce qu'il va y avoir
des problèmes en cours de route ?
Bien sûr qu'il y en a.
Aucune technologie ne vient
complètement formé,
et nous avons besoin des pionniers pour
pouvoir aller travailler là-dessus
et arriver au
déclarer ce que nous voulons.
Je pense que c'est très sain
que nous avons un tel
géants de la technologie
se battre publiquement,
pour que nous puissions tous former
un avis à ce sujet.
C'est un sport de spectateur
maintenant pour le reste d'entre nous.
Mark Zuckerberg voit
Elon comme un opposant
et quelqu'un qui essaie de
arrêter le développement de l’IA.
Je peux voir les deux côtés
de l'argumentation.
Je glisserais probablement légèrement
avec Mark Zuckerberg
dans le sens où je pense que nous
sera capable de contrôler l'IA
assez pour assurer la sécurité de l’humanité.
Je ne parierais pas contre Elon.
Tu sais si Elon pense
que l'IA va prendre le relais
et finalement décider
que nous sommes irrationnels
les humains sont inutiles,
Je lui ferais confiance.
Tu sais, il ne l'a pas fait
je me suis trompé sur beaucoup de choses.
Le débat est soit c'est un
c'est une bonne chose, il faut le faire.
C'est une mauvaise chose, mais nous
il faut le faire d'une autre manière.
Nous devrions arrêter
je le fais immédiatement
avant que la ligne ne soit franchie
où l'humanité n'est plus.
Il va y avoir une différence
entre ce qui est faisable
et ce qui est acceptable,
et c'est quelque chose qui
Elon ne va pas décider,
ce n'est pas quelque chose
que Mark Zuckerberg
ne va pas décider.
C'est toi et moi
et tout le monde,
et j'espère que
sera traduit
éventuellement dans une législation.
Inspiré
par les frustrations
d'être assis dans un embouteillage,
La solution de Musk était
La société ennuyeuse.
En 2018, l'entreprise était
sélectionné pour construire un système à grande vitesse
transport souterrain
système à Chicago.
Je voudrais remercier le
Maire et Cabinet du Maire,
et la ville de Chicago
pour avoir la foi
parier sur The Boring Company.
Nous pensons que nous allons vraiment
être très doué pour s'ennuyer.
On pourrait presque dire ça
Elon a la touche Midas,
parce que quand il a commencé
La société ennuyeuse,
ce qui concerne vraiment
ennuyeux sous la Terre
au lieu d'être ennuyeux,
il a en fait commencé à vendre
casquettes de baseball
avant de faire autre chose,
et littéralement fait
un million de dollars.
Tu sais, c'est un gars
qui tout ce qu'il touche
se transforme en or.
C'est une tâche difficile
chose que nous faisons.
C'est une chose difficile.
C'est une nouveauté.
Et toi, tu sais, j'espère que
tu nous encouragerais pour ça,
tu sais, parce que si nous réussissons,
ça va être génial
chose pour la ville,
et si nous échouons, eh bien,
Je suppose que moi et d'autres le ferons
perdre beaucoup d'argent.
Je pense que sa plus grande réussite
inspire l'humanité
voir plus grand,
rêver plus grand.
Dans un monde où il y a
tant de problèmes,
n'est-ce pas agréable d'avoir un
une histoire positive de temps en temps ?
Nous sommes tous en quelque sorte juste
s'asseoir et regarder
qu'est-ce qui va sortir ensuite.